[Music]
a woman in atlanta has quit her job
in order to pump enough breast milk to
feed her bodybuilding boyfriend every
two hours shut the [ __ ] up so what about
the baby what's the baby going to drink
muscle milk
the baby baby gets protein
and then powder the husband gets
this is that i'm like barbell brigade
[Laughter]
with taro
so what's the macros on breast milk
that's the macros it's not there's that
much protein in this breast milk
flavored protein powder well for him
they'd be drinking it two hours you said
what two hours every day let's see his
physique though is he [ __ ] just back
right
bart's like okay i guess it works ago
just has like big ass titties
he's all above but he's got white stains
forever here
i need to get some brushes what's the
science behind breast milk it's amazing
i like what it's in isn't it really high
fat i like what it's in high fat really
that's did we talk about this last time
oh i don't know that's why babies always
think i'm [ __ ] fat they're all fat
bro
breast milk factory which is this is
what this guy looks like
he looks like the giga chad filter
that's the giga chat filter that guy
looks [ __ ] jacked why is his neck so
long where's the rest of his body
available for curbside pickup
no way that's the guy dude he says
counterfeit viagra on there
you can't put what ads
they don't
that's [ __ ] crazy come on steve we
need to be better with the news man i
don't know we'll try it people come here
for the real news
we're gonna get we'll get better at it
next year next year we're focusing on
it's fake news with real jokes that's
true
fake news um so this woman gave birth to
her daughter she's 36 billion she gave
birth to her daughter 22 years ago and
she she had to dry breast she had to dry
breast feed every two hours and use a
breast thump uh use a breast pump to
fool her body back into lactation wait
what's dry breast feed so you just put
it on and you just let it pump until it
pumps is that what it is until milk
actually comes out so she'll do that for
two years
she needs to break up with this so it
just keeps going like this and then it
tricks the booby into thinking it's a
baby sucking it though what does she use
a dick pump it's not a dick pump just
there's a breast pump yeah
there's one for
i love big breast milk
does this work for me
is this also a breast pump like no it's
not no it's just for a dick i'm going to
try it anyway it says on the box i don't
trust you
what about this bicycle pump do you
think this will work
i never go to the breast style so i
don't know what they got impressed no
you do that's always the guys to say
they don't that do
for curiosity reasons yeah she believes
that adult breastfeeding will create a
magical bond between them and their
relationship oh it's emotional
for her but for him it's for jack
medicine and meanwhile yeah she she's
glad that her nursing will give his body
health benefits why does he just suck it
directly out like a man right what is it
what it doesn't say
no reason
what is it called
so you know if you're like eating out
her [ __ ] right and she's sucking her
dick that's 69 what if you're sucking on
her titty and then she's sucking on your
dick and white stuff goes both ways what
is that called first of all she's
talking about your dick and you got to
be really sure you got to be like this
torso yeah can you explain to the
viewers at home with 16 or this penis
has got to be like this long so that you
have that much room or you could crunch
your body maybe maybe you're flexible
and crunch it i would call that the p
doing the p the p the letter p
because you got to be the p
and she's the right piece that is
straight but what about the flow of
whiteness called the circle of white
why's it gonna be at the same time why
can't we just take turns that is
progressive as [ __ ] steve because that's
magical because you don't want to end up
with a deficit on one side i can't focus
i'll be honest with you guys i'm not
very good at 69. i can't focus really
why because you're just paralyzed
because it feels so good it in the other
dude's always [ __ ] my ass
[Laughter]
hey 69 in your guys's rotation of
movements i feel like it's like a once a
year thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think mutual
masturbation is more done than 69 yeah i
feel like 69 is played out how i bet
four stars are you know i don't know i
don't know what it is but like i feel
like we spent so much time [ __ ] using
69 as the butt of jokes that i kind of
like feel like i'll laugh if i do it
again
you get in that position you know when
guys always just say 69 as a joke most
of the time oh yeah you go we guys doing
they're 69
and then the next time you do it you're
like you want to laugh at yourself
what do you guys do
[Laughter]
i like
[Laughter]
it's like it's like this right there's a
certain technique that i want to do if i
want to do a good job right and for me i
can't focus on that if she's also
sucking on my dick it's your technique
this put both hands above your head and
chill
that's how steve [ __ ] or just come in
here bro you're coming here he doesn't
thrust because that's what he's doing
guys
this is my technique i heard on the
video that gay guys do that so i won't
do that only straight men relax and take
it so what was the article about it so
this is about monkeys
monkey's going extinct
it's the prompt of the day is if if 69
with a guy every second you did it luna
went up 0.01 would you do it for the
rest of your life 0.01 that's a lot dude
i don't need to
wow
i will i'll be done i need to i need
this thing to pump i'll do it after i
dump my whole [ __ ] stock
is there like actual um
is there a difference between like a
child receiving the nutritions from
breast milk versus an adult i think the
the only thing that i know about is the
uh antibodies thing so kids they don't
have as much right because they're not
they haven't been exposed to so many
viruses or whatever yeah so they can get
a lot of it from the breast milk
as an adult you might be just getting
you might be just getting the same exact
antibodies that you already have i'm
gonna look at the macros on breast milk
yeah look at this redundant milk by the
way this chick she was a bartender and
she says that she found a website um
about adult breast feeding relationships
called abr that's what it's called so
don't make fun please um she says i have
always enjoyed my breasts being touched
during sex more than anything else so i
knew i would enjoy this
i used dating sites put messages on abr
forms and even put an advertising um
listing on craigslist but i drew a blank
i started to think i would never get to
try adult breastfeeding eventually she
started talking with her former high
school boyfriend
and that's when she decided it was the
perfect time to bring up adult
breastfeeding see if he'd be down and
then he finds that it has a lot of
benefits for his workout out of all the
perverts in the world that guy's stupid
bro she hasn't found one man
that wanted breast milk no guys who
wanted to watch chicks eat out there how
come you can't find a guy who wants to
[ __ ] milk your titty you know what
though you know how like aunt owned that
liquor store right
so in the back of his liquor store he
had a porn
section with the curtain you could go in
and he said he would have customers that
would come in and say
when are you going to get the ones with
the milk
and he's all like what do you mean you
know the when they push the milk and
then it's the breast milk is a kiss with
your manager yeah and then he's all like
i don't even know where to get that and
then they were so mad at him like he's
like oh come on man well they're yucking
there yeah he's hurting there you go you
don't have he's like you don't it's well
he's acting like it's like a regular
kink you know like you don't have a
[ __ ] titty
you don't have tittie mills sounds like
a regular king to me joe did you find
the macros i did find the macros
all right so per 100 milliliters so it's
about three ounces
you get
65 calories
6.7 grams of carbohydrates
3.8 grams of fat and only 1.3 grams of
protein oh that sucks yeah so if you're
a bodybuilder it's all fat it's all
carbs mainly it's all carbs and fats no
point in this dude so just trying to fat
babies that's why babies will go [ __ ]
up yeah
they got no protein right it's basically
it's there's more protein in a milkshake
there's way more protein in a barbell
brigade
supplement protein that's true that's
just a sour gummy one there's more
protein in there
this poor [ __ ] woman bro is
dry milking yourself look at the macros
in a semen that i could do i don't know
that i know off the top of my head
because if you know
just from a scientific i believe it's
all carbs though i thought it's protein
nah
i think it's glucose
it probably is glucose yeah people just
lie and try to get bodybuilders to suck
more dick that's why they said there's
protein in the sperm
the average amount
i'm such a child it's a big problem in
the bodybuilding community guys getting
tricked in a second you tell any
bodybuilder that's the epidemic that's
how you could convince a bodybuilder to
suck your dick every anytime you go
dude when do you get a bodybuilding team
oh come on man that happens at the gym
all the time you're trying to get up
don't be like
i'm not trying to that's what i'm saying
you're giving us advice about trying to
get a bodybuilder not you but someone
out there who wants to get sucked off by
a bodybuilder ah okay got it has anybody
ever had their body a bodybuilder sucked
their dick off raise your hand oh
we see the experts not be active we're
joking this is just kidding news you
need consent before you raise your hands
oh what are you looking at me for do you
know the average protein concentration
of semen is five thousand forty
milligrams per 100 milliliter since one
since one ejaculation usually produces
five milliliters of semen we can see the
average amount less than the ejaculation
has 252 milligrams so that's not enough
protein how oyster has it i like to have
a ragged on [ __ ] true well we got to
think about the ratio though so if this
bodybuilder wants to get buff he should
stop trying to suck titty milk and start
sucking on some dicks yup that's more
protein though that's what we're trying
to get to that's what i of course
that's what i was trying to say jk
science dude or you don't have to suck
other guys dicks if you have a dick you
just suck your or you don't have to suck
your own dick against you
[Laughter]
we're like yeah what are the macros
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you